Prof: Okay,
we're in the middle of the
section on macroevolution.
We've had three lectures about
macroevolutionary principles:
speciation;
how to build a tree;
and then what kinds of uses you
can put a phylogenetic tree to.
Now we're going to do three
lectures on different ways to
look at the history of life.
And the first cut,
the first lecture,
the one today,
is an abstract conceptual view
of the history of life,
and it looks at it as a series
of major transitions in the
organization of life and how
information is transmitted.
And this is the structure of
the lecture.
We'll talk about what life is,
how we think it originated,
the origin of cells and
eukaryotes, some other key
events;
and then we'll summarize with
the principles that are involved
in key events,
in major transitions in
evolution.
Well, life is basically
anything that has the properties
of multiplication,
variation in heredity,
plus metabolism.
So it's not necessarily
carbon-based or silicon-based or
based on anything else;
it has these abstract
properties.
And what we really mean by
metabolism is something about
thermodynamics.
A living thing that has
metabolism is using free energy
that it's getting from the
environment,
and it's using that to maintain
a partially isolated system--
it's a local system;
your body is a partially
isolated local system--
and it's doing so to keep it in
an ordered state--
it's preserving the information
that evolution and development
have given it--
and it's doing so against an
entropy gradient.
So basically we eat energy and
we excrete entropy,
and the next time you're
looking at the toilet flushing
down,
think about all that entropy
that you're putting down into
the system.
Okay?
So this is what metabolism does.
Now if you try to do
experiments in the laboratory in
which you're watching the
evolution of RNA molecules,
or if you try to do in silico
experiments in the computer in
which you are looking at the
origin of structures--
and that can get to be pretty
sophisticated stuff--
you're not dealing with a
living system.
That's artificial.
Because with RNA,
we're providing the metabolism,
we're putting the ATP and the
enzymes into the test tubes,
and in programs for artificial
life,
the things that are evolving in
the computer are actually
getting their energy basically
from the electrical cable that
we've got plugged into the wall,
feeding the computer.
So if you can get,
independent of any human
intervention,
any system that's got
multiplication,
variation and heredity--so the
basics to make natural selection
work--
and you can arrange metabolism,
then it's going to start to
evolve,
and it will be alive.
So our problem is to figure out
how did this all get going?
The first major transition was
the transition from an abiotic
world to a living world;
the origin of life.
And to do that we had to get
multiplication,
variation, heredity and
metabolism.
And the answer is increasingly
that it is likely that
metabolism came first,
and that heredity and
multiplication came second;
variation was probably there
from the start.
So I'm going to actually dwell
on some things that are now
chemically fairly trivial,
and some things that are
logically non-trivial and
involve paradoxes.
Because this is an area that we
know it did happen;
and we can now break down the
steps in increasing detail,
but important things are not
understood.
So the environment at the
origin.
Gosh, I went through this thing
yesterday and I got all the
words on it, and then I start
talking and they're not there.
So the environment at the
origin.
The Big Bang is now dated at
about 13.5 billion years.
It was just a few years ago it
was dated at 20 billion years.
So the universe,
as we know it,
is a big younger than I had
thought a decade ago.
And in stars,
the nuclei of all of the
elements were synthesized out of
hydrogen,
basically, and some of the
novae and supernovae created
things that are heavier than
iron;
and a lot of that is important
cofactors for enzymes in your
body.
You could not actually function
biochemically as you do if you
did not have things that had
been cooked up in the explosions
of giant stars.
Now the solar system is formed
basically from recycled star
stuff,
about 5 to 4.5 billion years
ago, and there's intense
planetoid bombardment of the
inner planets going on at that
time.
Nothing living could have
existed on the face of the
earth, because temperatures were
simply too high;
the surface of the planet was
really a toxic wasteland of
boiling lava and very,
very extreme temperatures and
pHs.
The initial atmosphere got
blown off.
The moon was formed,
possibly because of the impact
of a large planetoid that hit
the forming earth and actually
blew a chunk of it off.
And at that point the earth had
short days;
it was spinning very rapidly.
It had condensed from a cloud
of stuff, and as it fell in,
it brought angular momentum
into the system.
And so the earth started off
with a higher rotation speed
than it currently has.
Then about a billion years
after the planet forms,
the atmosphere is reducing,
the temperature has fallen to
where liquid water can exist on
the surface of the planet.
And life probably originates on
a positively charged mineral
surface, and it seems now likely
that it was probably at a deep
hydrothermal vent.
So there was a hot
high-pressure acid around a
positively charged mineral
surface.
There was a lot of chemical
energy at that interface.
We don't know that for sure,
but this does seem to be the
kind of a context in which you
can get certain chemical
reactions to work,
that won't work elsewhere.
So you need the building blocks
of life.
You need linear lipids;
they can make membranes and
they can make compartments.
You need amino acids to make
proteins.
You need purines and
pyrimidines to make nucleotides.
You need sugars and phosphates
to link things together.
And so there's a branch of
Origin of Life research that
specializes in the chemical
conditions under which you'll
get this building blocks.
And then after you get the
building blocks,
and get them to work together,
you need things that will make
copies of themselves.
So if you can get reproduction,
variation in reproductive
success, some kind of
inheritance, then natural
selection will take over.
If you can get some kind of
primitive genetic molecule,
it can get honed into an RNA or
a DNA structure.
If you can get some kind of
primitive cell,
with a very simple membrane,
then natural selection can hone
it into a selective filter,
where there are pores in the
cell that let certain things in
and out,
and so forth.
So you have to have--you can
start with fairly simple things,
and natural selection will
refine them fairly rapidly,
but you have to start with at
least these simple things.
So that's kind of a bootstrap
operation.
You've got to get those first
replicators up and running
before natural selection will
take over and create complexity
and precision and make it into a
sophisticated system.
So how do you get the building
blocks?
Well there were some very
interesting experiments,
done by a grad student at the
University of Chicago,
Stanley Miller,
working with Harold Urey,
and what basically he did was
he would put methane,
nitrogen, ammonia,
ammonia chloride;
he would put in carbon
monoxide, nitrogen,
hydrogen, different kinds of
mixtures, into a vessel,
and then he would pass an
electric spark through it.
And he found that it was fairly
easy to get these amino acids to
fall out.
And, by the way,
most of this guy's Ph.D.
thesis consisted not of
performing that experiment,
but of doing the analytical
chemistry afterwards to convince
everybody that this was actually
what he had gotten.
Okay?
In 1953, that was not so easy;
we didn't have all these
beautiful gas chromatographs and
whatnot to do the
identifications.
Okay, so the basic structure of
this is that you make something
out of fairly small,
simple molecules,
likely to be in the atmosphere
or in the water,
on the surface of the earth,
3.5 to 4 billion years ago.
And you give it some energy in
the form of an electric charge,
or you heat it,
or whatever,
and you see what comes out.
So amino acids are pretty easy.
When I was 15-years-old,
I was fascinated by this
experiment in high school,
and I tried to repeat it,
and I blew up the chemistry
lab,
and I produced a toxic cloud of
cyanide gas--
which you can get out of these
guys--
and that caused the evacuation
of the entire building,
with 200 students sitting
outside on the lawn,
in the middle of morning
classes;
it was deeply satisfactory.
>
Okay, so we have a bit of
ambivalence on this issue of
abiotic synthesis.
Some things we get real easy.
Okay?
We get amino acids,
fatty acids,
sugars and purines pretty
easily.
Some things are hard.
So pyrimadine nucleotides;
ribose is not so easy.
A linear, long-chain,
fatty acid, that you might find
really useful for making a
membrane, that's not so easy.
And it's not easy to get these
things all in the same synthetic
environment.
So you have to imagine that
well perhaps we're getting
different chemical reactions
going on in different micro
environments,
and they're mixing somehow.
But then once we've got the
building blocks,
you run into what is not a
chemical synthesis problem,
you run into an abstract
logical problem.
Okay?
That's the error threshold.
So the amount of information
that you can maintain by
selection is limited by copying
fidelity.
Basically what that says is
that if you have a very high
mutation rate,
you are destroying all of the
information that you've
accumulated,
and you're not transmitting
enough of it to the next
generation to be able to
usefully accumulate information
on how to do something better.
So that's the error threshold.
If you don't really have high
copying fidelity,
then mutations will kill you.
And if you have a small
genome--basically if you have a
small genome that's big enough
to do something--
it can actually have a higher
mutation rate than a large
genome.
A small genome is small enough
so that the probability of a
mutation at any one place in it
is fairly small.
A big genome is extremely
likely to have a bunch of
mutations.
So there's a relationship
between the size of the genome
and the amount of mutation that
can be tolerated.
So Manfred Eigen--he's a German
guy who got a Nobel Prize for
his work in biochemistry--
was thinking about the origin
of life,
and he said,
"Well, the relevant
mutation rate is non-enzymatic
replication.
We're going to be making copies
of molecules,
and at the origin there aren't
any enzymes anymore."
Okay?
Enzymes are things that are
produced by living systems;
we don't have them.
We have to imagine ourselves
back into the situation where we
don't have enzymes but we want
replication.
And for that,
it turns out--he did the
calculations--the maximum genome
size is about 100 nucleotides.
So if we're dealing with
replication of a DNA-like or an
RNA-like molecule,
you can only get up to a genome
of about 30 amino acids with the
kinds of mutation rates you get
with non-enzymatic replication.
Well that's much,
much too small for an enzyme.
You're not going to get an
enzyme out of that.
Anything bigger than that,
you need to make the
replication more accurate,
and in order to make it more
accurate you need an enzyme.
You need translating machinery
to take the genome and make it
into that enzyme;
you need the enzyme then to be
working on making the genome
replicate accurately.
And that takes a lot more than
100 nucleotides;
it takes more like 1000 to
10,000 nucleotides to construct
any of the things that we know
of now that can do that.
And so you can't get enzymes
without a big genome,
and you can't get a big genome
without enzymes.
It's a catch-22.
Where are you going to go?
So Eigen tried to cook up a way
out of this, and he called it
hypercycles.
And the word hyper
immediately makes you think of
something that's almost
quasi-metaphysical.
It's nothing complicated.
Okay?
Here's what a hypercycle is.
Each one of these little things
here is a chemical reaction,
and this little loop that I'm
pointing at,
where B is making something
that's making more B,
indicates that B is actually
capable of making more of
itself;
it's a chemical reaction that
can make more of itself.
And there are a lot of such
chemical reactions.
Often, in a chemical reaction,
you'll get product out of one
side, plus some other stuff
that's like what you started
with.
And this big dark arrow here
indicates that some of what B
makes is actually a precursor
for C.
So C needs something that B is
making, and it takes it and
makes more of itself,
and then it ships something on
that D needs to make more of
itself;
and D takes that and makes more
of itself and ships something on
that makes A;
etcetera.
Okay?
So if you can set up--it's
called a hypercycle because it's
a cycle with cycles inside of
it;
it's a cycle of cycles.
The rate at which any one of
these can replicate increases
with the amount of product
that's being given to it by any
of the others.
And that means that B can make
more B if it's getting more from
A;
C can make more C if it's
getting more from B.
That means that in order to
function, the elements have to
cooperate for substrate.
They can't compete for
substrate.
They have to take what they
need and pass some on.
And if this is then going to
get refined and become more
sophisticated,
and perhaps get to the point
where it acquires an information
molecule like DNA,
then it has to competitively
exclude other such systems.
You could imagine a surface at
a hot thermal vent,
3.5 billion years ago,
with many different such
things;
a high degree of variation in
just tiny little micro,
local chemical reaction
systems.
And if this is ever going to
bootstrap life and get underway,
then it has to be isolated in a
compartment and start competing
with other such systems,
because only then will natural
selection kick in.
There is a problem with this
kind of thing.
It's just sitting there in its
happy, hot thermal vent,
taking its chemical energy out
of the environment.
And it's open,
it's an open system.
A selfish mutant could invade
and destroy it.
Somebody could come in,
who was say an alternate
version of C,
and take stuff from B and make
a lot more C,
but not ship anything on to D;
it could make a lot more C.
That would essentially be a
selfish act.
Okay?
That means taking but not
giving back.
And in this system here,
an altruistic mutant won't
spread;
and altruistic means
taking some and passing enough
along.
So if this thing is open,
and it's not isolated from the
environment,
any one of these steps in the
hypercycle could be invaded by a
chemical alternative that would
destroy the hypercycle.
So these things are a model.
Okay?
We're not saying that this is
what actually happened,
but it is a model of how a
small group of cooperating
molecules might have evolved,
before there was a genetic code.
If we could get them to be
sufficiently complex,
then they would start competing
with each other,
and then, at a certain point in
the complexity,
they might invent genes and
have a competitive upper hand by
then being able to transmit the
information on what was working.
So that would certainly give
them an upper hand in
competition.
And they would solve Eigen's
paradox, because each one has a
small genome,
but in sum they would add up to
the information in a big genome.
So if you could somehow
stabilize these small
competitive systems so that they
had internal cooperation but
they were competing between
themselves,
you could get life going.
So one way out of this problem
of the invasion of mutants is to
actually put them into
compartments.
Okay?
So you actually have to get the
chemical reaction system
isolated inside something like a
membrane;
and that means it's a local
group.
Will, are you finding certain
things here resonating?
Will's a political scientist,
and he's interested in the
interaction between cooperation
within groups and competition
between groups.
Those basic ideas,
that actually resonate in
economics and political science,
are there in evolutionary
biology, right at the origin of
life.
In order to get this going,
in order to get the whole
process going,
basically what you need to do
is isolate one of those
hypercycles,
let it grow,
have some kind of division
going on,
with some inheritance,
and then have a mutation that's
going to improve one of the
descendents,
so that this one,
that has a better hypercycle,
can out-compete that one.
Once you get that process
going, then you're going to
retain cooperation within
compartments,
you're going to increase
competition between
compartments,
and natural selection can take
off and start to produce the
very early primitive cells.
That's not so easy.
You got to get the
compartments,
and there's some issues about
the compartments.
You need them so that you can
keep the cooperators on the
inside and you can put the
parasites and the defectors on
the outside;
so you can keep the guys that
you like and you want to work
with in there with you,
and you can tell the other guys
to go away.
What this does,
it's associating cause with
effect strongly,
in the sense that if you're
cooperating and you are shipping
your product on to the next
member of the hypercycle,
that actually is an effect
that's retained within the
system and then comes back to
help you.
If it's open,
you have no guarantee it's
going to come back to help you.
So there's no guarantee of
reciprocity.
But if you can contain the
cycle, then reciprocity is going
to occur because the cycle is
shielded from the outside.
And it means that all of the
elements in the cycle have a
common stake in the success of
the compartment.
They are all in the same boat;
they're all in it together.
If they get better at what they
do, together,
by cooperation,
they will improve their
competition with the other
similar things on the outside.
Now, we don't know where the
long-chain fatty acids came
from.
So I'm just going to pull them
out of the air;
we're back in Greek comedy,
deus ex machina--a machine
lowers a god onto the stage and
he gives us long-chain fatty
acids.
So we have our long-chain fatty
acids;
and, in fact,
we have a special kind.
They've got a hydrophilic end
and a hydrophobic end.
There's a b-o missing there;
that's hydrophobic.
So one end likes water and one
end hates water.
And if you do that,
if you make those things and
you throw them into water--so
you have an aqueous
solution--this is what you'll
get.
These are things which are
either micelles or primitive
little spheroids or sometimes
linear things,
that actually start looking
pretty much like a biological
membrane.
The fatty tails are sticking in
and associating with each other,
and the hydrophilic parts are
sticking out and associating
with all of those nice charged
water molecules.
Well, make a mixture of those
things,
and then put in a surface--so
you have either the water
surface or you have a mineral
surface--
and this is what naturally
happens.
This is called abstriction;
you will get a little bump
forming.
We're talking about stuff
that's there for free,
in the sense that you don't
have to have any natural
selection going on to give this
to you,
in the chemical structures.
These things,
once you get them,
will do this spontaneously.
Okay?
So you can get something like
this happening--
this is a nice little sphere
that's starting to bulge up off
the surface--
and if you make them big
enough, they will divide.
So they will grow and they'll
actually kind of start pulsing
around a little bit,
just from Brownian motion.
And if you get these little
spheroids, that are lipid
bilayers, up to a certain size
they will actually divide.
So you can see that it might
not actually have been necessary
for natural selection to arrange
the first replication events for
cellular compartments.
That might have been something
that was just happening
physically and chemically,
so that part of the
bootstrapping was there for
free.
Making it efficient,
making it good,
making it precise,
making it complicated,
that's a whole 'nother story;
that took a lot of evolution.
But just that very simple
initial step of having a sphere
of a bilipid membrane that had a
hypercycle in it--
maybe one in each compartment
that would then divide--
that was probably there for
free.
Now, if you want to make it
grow, then one of the things you
want to put inside it is a
hypercycle that will make more
membrane building blocks,
because that will just make the
thing grow.
So perhaps that was actually
the kind of chemical reaction
that was going on in some of the
early semi-cells or proto-cells;
they were making the building
blocks of lipid bilayers.
However, then you've got a
problem of how to get the
different substrates that you
need in through the membrane;
that's the problem of membrane
transport.
You've got to have the membrane.
You've got to isolate your
reactions so that they can be
cooperative and not
de-stabilized by parasites.
But once you've isolated them,
then you have the problem of
moving things in and out through
the membrane.
So there's got to be a period,
back at the origin of life,
during which membrane
properties can evolve,
and that in a replicating
entity that's not yet fully cut
off from its environment.
And the solution to that,
one possible solution is a
semi-cell.
That would be you make a cup on
the surface of water,
or on the surface of a mineral,
and you don't completely close
the perimeter.
So the thing's kind of leaky;
stuff can go in and out of the
edges of the cup.
And that will solve the problem.
Okay?
It allows a partial openness,
it gives you a certain degree
of control over who comes in and
out,
and that might've helped to
adjust these early semi-cells.
If you want to have a look at a
fairly recent article--
this is now five years
old--Rasmussen was talking about
transitions from non-living to
living matter in Science.
And then this would be a good
way, in Web of Science,
to go and trace the more recent
literature.
They will all--all the more
recent articles will almost
certainly cite this one;
and then it also cites you back
all the way to the Miller-Urey
experiments in 1953.
So there's really growing
interest in how a simple life
form could be synthesized in the
lab,
and there is a desire to see
whether or not we can understand
the origin of life well enough
so that we can make alternate
forms of life,
so that we can make
self-replicating and
self-repairing nanomachines.
And Drew Endy,
up at MIT, runs an
international competition every
year where bright young
molecular geneticists and
microbiologists get together and
they try to engineer biological
machines.
And the point of the
competition is to try to make
the most complex and
sophisticated little biological
machine that you can.
And he's got funding from MIT
to bring these people from all
over the world.
So every year there's an
international competition and a
team comes in from Beijing and a
team comes in from Paris,
and if Yale puts one together,
a team goes up from Yale,
and they all play with their
biological machines,
which are at the scale of
viruses and bacteria.
So out of this kind of creative
play,
we may actually learn a lot,
that then applies back to the
real origin of life,
rather than the geeky
post-modern nanomachine,
so I see some hope in that kind
of playful research.
Okay, now I will wave my hands
and a miracle occurs and it's
later on in the evolution of
life.
We're now going to discuss the
prokaryotic/eukaryotic
transition.
And the prokaryotic/eukaryotic
transition is thought to be a
major transition because it
contains a significant change in
the transmission of information.
Every major transition in the
evolution of life has consisted
either of a difference in the
way that genetic information was
transmitted and/or in the unit
of selection;
a thing that was actually
evolving.
So both of those things are
going on here.
What's going on in the
transition from the prokaryotes,
up here, to the eukaryotes,
down here,
is--one thing that's going
on--is that you're going from an
organism,
like a bacterium,
that has a single circular
chromosome anchored to a cell
wall,
to an organism that has a
nucleus within which the
chromosomes are--
there are then often multiple
chromosomes inside the nucleus,
plus organelles that are out in
the cytoplasm,
plus a lot of cell structure
that's simply not present in the
prokaryotes.
So one of the things that you
have is an organizing center,
out of which actin filaments
will grow, and these are used in
meiosis and mitosis.
And associated with that
organizing center is a little
circular chromosome which is
actually thought to indicate
that this was originally an
independent bacterium,
and that these actin filaments
are evolutionary homologous with
a bacterial flagellum.
You have got vacuoles,
you've got endoplasmic
reticulum;
all kinds of stuff.
And all eukaryotes,
if they have a cilium,
they have a characteristic 9 2
structure,
in the cilium,
and this is thought to have
been constructed from multiple
bacterial precursors,
and so forth.
So you've got compartments
forming,
you've got organelles,
and you've got a difference in
the way that genetic information
is compartmentalized and
transmitted.
So the prokaryotes have a rigid
outer cell wall,
they have a circular chromosome
attached to the cell wall;
and importantly the transcribed
mRNA is translated directly.
You can see that here.
You can see the mRNA coming off
of the DNA helix,
and you can see little
ribosomes here chunking out
protein, that are these little
squiggly things;
whereas down here,
that process is being done at
the endoplasmic reticulum,
and it's not direct,
it's indirect.
In the eukaryotes there's an
internal cytoskeleton.
You've got lots of little micro
environments that are giving you
the opportunity to create local
industry within the cytoplasm.
There are several linear
chromosomes, inside a nuclear
envelope;
transcription and translation
are separated;
and there are organelles.
And, with eukaryotes,
you get meiosis.
So you get a precise and
organized way of making
genetically different offspring
in each generation.
Now, in order to go from
prokaryote to eukaryote,
you got to lose your cell wall.
And that's a real issue,
because the cell wall,
in a bacterium,
is protecting it from swelling
up and bursting like a balloon,
due to osmotic pressure.
So the bacterium is using a
rigid cell wall to protect
itself from the influx of water.
And in order to do that,
in order to lose the cell wall,
you need something to stabilize
it on the inside,
and that's the cytoskeleton.
So the cytoskeleton is really
an extremely important
morphological invention in this
transition.
Student:  Professor.
Prof: Yep?
Student:  How does this
view connect with the fact that
cytoskeleton elements have been
discovered in bacteria as well?
Also cytoskeleton elements are
present in bacteria.
Prof: Well you would
need to have cytoskeleton
elements in the precursor,
wouldn't you?
You couldn't make the
transition unless they were
already there.
If you made the transition
without them,
you would blow up.
So I'm not surprised that there
are cytoskeletal elements in
bacteria.
Okay, and remember,
it's 3 billion years later.
So a lot of stuff could've gone
on, in the bacteria.
I think that what you're on to
actually is an interesting
system to see whether or not you
could actually do experimental
evolution.
What is the state of the cell
wall in this bacteria?
Do you know?
Student:
>
Prof: They don't have a
cell wall.
Student:  They have a
normal cell wall.
Prof: They have a normal
cell wall.
If this idea is correct,
then of course it should be
possible--it might take a long
time--to experimentally select
them, to lose their cell walls.
But in order to do so,
they would probably have to
organize their fibrils,
their cytoskeleton,
in a very precise way before
they could do it.
Just having them--they're
probably using it for some other
reason.
Student: They
actually--some of cytoskeleton
is thought to re-mediate,
or regulate,
cell wall synthesis.
Prof: Is thought to
re-mediate--
Student:  Thought to
regulate cell wall synthesis.
Prof: I can't hear the
last part of that.
Student:  Is thought to
regulate cell wall synthesis.
Prof: Cell wall
synthesis.
Some of the cytoskeleton is
actually involved in cell wall
synthesis.
So that would suggest that it
was there for a long time.
That is actually how evolution
works;
it invents things for one
purpose, and then takes
advantage of them for another.
So what you're telling me is
actually that this scenario now
has all kinds of supporting
information,
because the bacteria probably
had evolved for a long time,
using the cytoskeleton for
another purpose.
But then, having gotten it,
they were in a position to use
it to keep from blowing up,
if they got rid of their cell
wall.
But they did have to get rid of
their cell wall to become a
eukaryote.
Okay?
By the way, I definitely accept
the fact that I don't know
everything.
So I appreciate that.
Now if you put your DNA into a
nucleus,
and you no longer have it as a
single circular chromosome,
then it is possible that
without having to attach it to a
cell wall,
it might make it easier to make
multiple chromosomes.
And you get a big advantage
from that in terms of how big a
genome you can have,
because you can then start
replication in parallel,
at multiple points,
rather than going around a
single circular chromosome to do
it.
And that means that there
really would be no upper limit
on genome size.
If you can make 100 small
chromosomes and start them all
off at the same time,
in replication,
you'll get through the
replication step very quickly.
So there's an issue about the
origin of chromosomes.
That's actually a major
transition in the sense of how
is the genetic material
organized
On the one hand there's this
replication advantage.
Okay?
So you can make copies a lot
faster if you do it in parallel,
in small pieces,
than in sequence,
in big pieces.
And so that would be a cost of
having a bigger chromosome.
You might want to have a
chromosome of intermediate size.
And if it's taking an
interaction between two or more
genes to produce either an
organism or to produce a
biochemical reaction system that
has a certain ratio,
that is well balanced in terms
of product,
then linking the genes that are
involved in that ensures that
they'll both be found in all of
the offspring,
and that's a benefit of making
a bigger chromosome.
So there would be a tendency
for the genome to agglutinate,
if this were the only thing
going on.
But it's balanced by this cost;
this benefit is balanced by
that cost.
And I'm sure there are other
things as well;
I'm sure you can probably think
of some.
Now once you make chromosomes
and you synchronize their
replication,
then essentially what you've
done is you have eliminated the
competition of the genes.
Because by putting the genes
onto a chromosome,
you've put them all into the
same boat.
You're no longer getting a
situation where one gene might
be replicating at a higher rate
than another gene,
which would lead to unbalanced
biochemistry and unbalanced
development.
So you've given them a stake in
the same process,
and that process is the
replication of the chromosome on
which they are sitting.
So particularly for the genes
that were involved in
replication, if they needed to
cooperate to replicate,
this would be an important
consideration.
Now if you've got a primordial
cell that has a lot of reactions
going on in it,
that are being controlled by
genes that are all on separate
chromosomes,
and if those chromosomes are
not being divided evenly at
mitosis and meiosis,
then it's possible that all
those reaction systems are going
to get out of balance.
Okay?
And so if you've got unlinked
genes with products that need a
certain ratio,
then getting them onto the same
chromosome and regulating them
all together,
gives you a big advantage over
your competitors,
at that point.
I'm sorry this is running off.
I think it shows up on your
printouts.
Okay, now the other thing
that's going on in the
eukaryotes is they've got these
symbiotic organelles that were
originally independent bacteria:
the mitochondria,
the chloroplasts,
and possibly the spindle
apparatus.
So one thing that we notice
when we look at the chloroplasts
in the mitochondria is that the
chloroplasts have a much bigger
genome than do the mitochondria,
and the mitochondrial genes
have been transferred into the
nucleus.
We can sequence the
mitochondria--we know that they
were independent purple
bacteria--
and we can estimate from the
size of the genome of a purple
bacterium how much has now been
transferred into the eukaryotic
nucleus;
and we can see that a great
deal has been transferred into
the eukaryotic nucleus.
So one of the reasons to do
that is essentially efficiency.
If you put those genes into the
nucleus,
you're just maintaining two
copies of them,
rather than thousands of copies
out in the population of
mitochondria that are living in
the cell.
Another is conflict resolution.
Basically you're cutting way
down on the opportunity for
different variants to exist in
mitochondrial processes.
If you're constructing all of
the mitochondria out of
essential elements that are in
your nuclear genome,
you've gotten control over
them, in a way,
and you are making them all
look the same,
rather than mutating and
possibly having the option of
creating a runaway mitochondrial
cancer that would destroy your
metabolism.
Now why not put all the genes
into the nuclear genome?
Well there are a couple of
reasons.
One is that the genetic code is
actually different in the
mitochondria and in eukaryotes
and in the nuclear genome and in
the chloroplast.
So the tRNA and ribosomal RNA
genes, the translation machinery
had to be retained in the
mitochondrion;
at least that much.
Now that explains the
mitochondrion,
but it doesn't explain the
chloroplast.
It looks like the chloroplast
retains more genes because it
has to move macro molecules
through more layers of membrane.
Remember, the world record on a
chloroplast is that it has four
membranes around it,
and all chloroplasts have two
membranes around them.
So it's harder to move big
molecules through them,
and so if you need them to make
the chloroplast function,
you have to make more of them
locally.
So that's probably one reason
for the retention of more genes
in the chloroplast genome than
in the mitochondrial genome.
Do we think that the organelles
were originally slaves of the
things that ate them?
Was it a relationship that
might have been like a farmer
and livestock,
the way that corals harvest
dinoflagellates,
that are helping them make
their carbonate skeletons?
Well, there's some evidence.
We can look at where are the
tapping proteins made that are
inserted into the organelle
membranes?
And those are encoded in the
nucleus.
Okay?
And it looks like they evolve
from host proteins.
So it looks like there have
been manipulative steps where
the host was actually tapping in
to the symbiotic organelles;
that's one piece of evidence.
But there's also thought that
they may have been mutualists,
and the excretory products of
one of them,
which was a eubacterium,
it was making hydrogen and CO2.
And the missing piece of this
sentence basically is that that
would then have been food for
the archaean ancestor of the
eukaryotic nucleus.
So they could have actually
been mutualists.
So there is a slave hypothesis
and there's a mutualistic
hypothesis, and that hasn't been
settled.
Why not just have one;
why do plants need to have two?
And if you look at their
ancestors,
you can see that purple
non-sulfur bacteria and
cyanobacteria--
so those are the ancestors of
mitochondria and chloroplasts--
they can do both;
they can both photosynthesize
and they can respire.
However, the purple bacteria
can't photosynthesize when
there's oxygen,
and the cyanobacteria use the
same machinery for both
functions,
and so that means that the host
cell would not be able to
separately control
photosynthesis and respiration;
which one might want to
uncouple.
And so it appears that
mitochondria lost photosynthesis
and chloroplasts lost
respiration, in coming into the
cell.
So I won't run through all of
this;
you can read through it if you
want.
Basically what's going on here
is the world record for
membranes around a chloroplast
is 4;
it's in a dinoflagellate.
And what's going on here is
that one thing eats
cyanobacterium,
and that makes a chloroplast
that has the outer membrane of a
cyanobacterium and the outer
membrane of the cell that ate
it,
wrapped around it;
so that makes two.
And then it happens two more
times.
And so the world record for
this is in a dinoflagellate.
Okay?
And it turns out that the
things that got eaten to make
dinoflagellates had separated,
so that there were different
kind of chloroplasts that got
eaten by different things,
that both ended up making
dinoflagellates.
And so it looks like,
in that sense,
dinoflagellates might be
polyphyletic.
It's a complicated sequence
here.
And you will notice in here
that you have got some
interesting words:
rhodophytes;
photosynthetic stramenophiles;
haptophytes;
the dinoflagellates themselves.
It would be worth doing a
Google Image search on those
things, just to familiarize
yourself with this bit of
Protistan biodiversity.
There are more things out
there, in the world,
than our fantasies can imagine.
And these guys are specialists
in all kinds of weird genetics.
So I just want to cue you to
that.
We're not going to go--this
isn't a course in protistology,
but there's been an awful lot
of interesting evolutionary
biology that's gone on in these
single-celled creatures.
So that's a dinoflagellate.
They're cool things.
They have a--it's kind of a bit
like a small algal cell sitting
inside of a complicated glass
case.
So there are some other key
events: origin of the genetic
code;
origin of multicellularity;
origin of germline and soma;
origin of social groups;
origin of language.
It's a big topic,
and in each one of these steps
there are several very important
things going on,
and there are certain
similarities of the process in
each one of those steps.
So I'd like to summarize those,
with a few principles that are
involved.
So one of the things that's
happening here is that there is
a new level of selection,
there's a new level of
replication;
the hierarchy is growing.
So you go from the hypercycle
into competing groups of
protocells, and those eventually
make a prokaryote.
And then there are symbiotic
events, and you actually then
have selection operating on a
eukaryotic cell that's got two
or three genomes in it.
And then in the process the
genetic material,
of course, is also going
through its reorganization into
chromosomes.
And then after that,
you get multicellularity;
you get cells that are probably
genetically almost identical,
that are growing together;
you get division of labor
within that.
So one of the things that
happens is that the babushka
doll, the number of levels in
the hierarchy grows.
When that new upper level
originates, then there's an
opportunity for functional
specialization and division of
labor.
In the multicellular organism
we call this division of labor
the origin of cell layers and
organ systems,
so that some cells make brains
and other cells make hearts;
some do respiration,
some do excretion.
That would be a multicellular
division of labor.
In a social insect colony,
we would say that the queen has
specialized on reproduction,
and then we have the different
castes that are doing things.
Some of them are cleaning up
the garbage in the colony;
some of them are feeding the
queen;
some of them are foraging
outside.
And you can see the analogy to
a human society as well.
So there's functional
specialization with division of
labor.
There is a change in the system
of information transmission.
So when you go from prokaryotes
to eukaryotes,
you have to arrange for
information to be transmitted,
not only in the nuclear genome,
but also in the cytoplasmic
genomes.
And then you have the evolution
of meiosis, and you have sexual
reproduction;
which is a huge change in the
way information is transmitted.
Probably since the origin of
sex, the biggest- highest impact
change in information
transmission has been the origin
of language and culture,
which gives a method of
transmitting information from
generation to generation,
that is independent of the DNA,
and allows the process to be
going on in different directions
at two levels.
Then often in the process of
forming this higher level of
replication,
you have a bunch of lower level
units that are coming together
to make a higher level unit,
and they need to cooperate to
do that properly,
but they could be invaded by
selfish mutants,
they could be de-stabilized,
and so there's a conflict
issue.
And this conflict is sometimes
stabilized by selection for
cooperation.
You've heard me use several
times in this lecture a phrase
like 'they're all in the same
boat' or 'they are all sharing
mutual interests',
as in the genes getting
together on a chromosome,
or the chemical reactions
coming together in a single
protocell.
Those are all principles of
conflict resolution,
because if you are in a tightly
spatially organized system,
where your own welfare depends
directly upon cooperation with
another thing in that system,
and your system is in
competition with some outside
system,
and the performance of your
system is actually a direct
function of how cooperative you
are,
then there is strong selection
for integration,
within that group.
And it's thought that this is
the kind of thing that's going
on when you have a key event in
the origin of a new higher level
in the evolutionary hierarchy.
So those are some of the key
events in evolution.
They are a rather abstract way
of looking at the history of
life.
And next time we're going to
look at major events in the
geological theater,
and so the lecture next time is
more for people who like
firecrackers on the 4th of July,
and the clash of meteorites.